talking of your other shows um i think
it was an american kitchen nightmares
where they claimed their toaster didn't
work do you know what i'm talking about
i was sitting at louisiana and i was
undercover as a band member
and i kept on saying to the team because
we got the surveillance and so
i know how bad it is i just said play it
safe
stick to a caesar salad and ask for some
toast
and so this toast came but the smell was
really weird
and i went over to the toaster turned
upside down and
you know out came a frazzled freaking
mouse oh sorry
i said to the uh front of the house i
said can you smell that singed hair
oh we don't use that side of the toaster
you know the mouse is in there
the toast to this side is broke
seriously yeah grim yeah really great
because
sometimes i know you watch though and
you worry for him i do worry for him but
i think
you know what makes me feel like yeah
you know what he's the don
he's like when i saw him going to a west
indian restaurant and told the woman off
about her jerk i was like if you can go
to a west indian restaurant
and confront an old-school granny a
jamaican granny like you're a dog you're
part of the
you can come to family christenings